hello and welcome to the agenda
place young people first for this new
week of parliamentary committees
erasmus becomes erasmus plus last year
the european program
of exchanges was threatened with extinction
today it is not only saved
but it will evolve  erasmus plus
cover education training youth
and for the first time sport meeting
in the culture committee on tuesday november 5
the deputies should also vote on
access to cheaper loans for
students wishing to do their
masters in a foreign country how
get young people out of the spiral of
unemployment when in europe nearly one
in four young people is unemployed the
parliament is organizing the citizens' agora on
youth unemployment from 6 to 8 november
each member state will be represented by
two young people aged between 18  and 30 years old one
is unemployed the other already employed
for three days the participants will
debate the
conclusions of this ago  civic
will be communicated to European decision-makers
crisis management the time to take
stock sounded on 5 November the deputies
of the Economics Committee will
kick off an
investigation process intended to take
stock of crisis management in
europe several public hearings and
meeting of experts are scheduled between now and
spring to assess the work of the
troika between now and april 2014 as a reminder the
troika is made up of representatives of
the european union the international monetary fund
and the bank
European central and finally what to do with
this in europe 40% of waste
comes from packaging made most
often of plastic material according to the
principle to save resources
we must better manage our waste a
report from parliament proposes to
gradually ban the implementation  landfill
and incineration of plastics to
promote their recycling
objective 75% recycled plastic in
europe by 2020 the vote of the te  xte in the
environment committee is scheduled for November 5
and until then have a good week